hello and welcome to omixlogic in this
video i will introduce our data science
training and explain how you can use
various resources to learn about
biomedical data analysis visualization
and integration data science is a
desired profession that brings together
diverse skills needed to handle data and
turn it into useful information some of
the highest paying and interesting jobs
are for data scientists at high-tech
companies like apple google and uber and
more recently healthcare and
biotechnology companies these industries
are relying on scientific discoveries
about biology and translating the basic
understanding of biological processes
into useful insights for many tasks like
drug discovery improved treatment
efficacy as well as early detection of
risks and even anticipation of disease
progression
these data intensive applications offer
a deeper look at what's going on and
require computational analysis skills
that today can be learned by anyone
engineer or biologist
in this program we will cover practical
and conceptual aspects of machine
learning in application to high
throughput biomedical data using various
data analysis tools r and python
throughout the course students will get
an understanding of opportunities and
limitations of machine learning in the
context of basic and translational
biomedical research projects for
pre-clinical and clinical applications
where can you find data on such projects
one repository that we will explore
together is maintained by the national
center for biotechnology information or
ncbi
in the past several years this database
has been growing exponentially and today
there are over 100 000 publicly
available data sets in just one part of
the ncbi called geo which stands for
gene expression omnibus
there are also over 15 petabytes of raw
sequence archives and an exponential
growth of gin bank sequences
representing over 5 million different
organisms
not only is this a lot of data but it's
also data that is highly variable there
are many different formats and platforms
for data generation making it extremely
heterogeneous
one key technology driving this
explosion and data is omix omix
technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cell of an organism
many types of omics data can be
generated using next generation
sequencing or what is also known as high
throughput sequencing to analyze such
data novel computational technologies
have been developed that are
transforming life sciences enabling
biotechnology and empowering biomedical
research as a result researchers are
making new discoveries every day
understanding this data the technologies
used to produce it and techniques for
its analysis are now critical to
understand for anyone across the whole
life cycle of data
from lab technicians to data scientists
and
decision makers
in this program you will learn about
analytical methods for processing
visualization and analysis of complex
biomedical data you will understand the
terminology for machine learning and
artificial intelligence and biomedical
discovery and see project examples where
machine learning was used effectively to
achieve meaningful results
you will also hear about commonly used
machine learning algorithms for
analyzing all mixed data understand the
differences between machine learning
models and problems they can be applied
to
see the different applications of
machine learning for omics studies and
project design objectives and gain
experience with popular python and r
packages for data visualization analysis
and machine learning
most importantly you will learn to use
your understanding to work on industrial
and research problems of the 21st
century
precision medicine population health
biotechnology
agriculture and space onyx each session
is designed to cover the topics in a
practical and informative way
starting from the very basics and
covering topics appropriate for both
intermediate and advanced levels
depending on how far you want to go with
this program you can choose to stay
within the scope of the syllabus or
explore beyond what is covered in each
live session with asynchronous materials
that are also included
the program syllabus is organized into
three parts
introduction
in-depth review of methods
and applications of machine learning to
a project
every onyx logic program comes with
comprehensive resources to make it
easier for anyone to learn data science
and bioinformatics these include
comprehensive training materials data
analysis tools that you can use on the
cloud and an interactive coding console
for assignments
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing online community
of bioinformaticians and training as a
result we have developed two key
technologies to make this program more
interactive
the first one is a big data analysis
platform
called the t bioinfo developed at the
tower bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa in israel
the second one was designed to
supplement
the materials that are on the platform
with interactive coding tutorials as
well as practical projects that you can
analyze data from to really learn about
the application of the different machine
learning methods on the portal you will
find access to big data analysis tools
and high quality learning resources that
include courses projects and tutorials
these help simplify data for
visualization and use it to spot
relationships and patterns and complex
data sets
these exercises will include learning
and practicing scripting and
understanding how to analyze and
visualize various omics data to extract
meaningful insights from large
biological datasets
you will also learn to use popular
online coding and data storage resources
like google colab jupyter notebooks
shiny applications and r as well as
github
it's time to get started
let's start
learning about data science for
biomedical data